it's the first time in five days that
neder can enter this room in his home
he says he and his family were asleep
when the waters came cascading
he's now trying to salvage what he can
we escaped with the clothes on our back
and left everything behind
the waters came from a valley in the
east and kept rising quickly
it's only this morning that some streams
that were blocked
were opened and the levels have gone
down a bit but water keeps coming
more than 60 houses in nadir's
neighborhood have been partially or
completely destroyed by the rising
waters
the result of heavy rains coming off the
mountains and swelling rivers
people say it's the worst i've seen in
years
this used to be part of my home but the
walls and ceilings have collapsed
my savings were in this room as well as
important documents
all have been washed away along with
some things i brought to sell people
officials say at least 10 000 people
have been affected
and more than 2 000 have been displaced
sudan's government says more floods are
expected in many parts of the country
during the annual rainy season in august
and has urged those at risk to take
necessary precautions
while some families have opted to stay
in their homes despite the floods
others had no option but to leave the
state authorities have been criticized
for not acting fast enough
and as it's only the start of the rainy
season it's feared that
more houses are in danger of collapse
and that more people will suffer
this school is where some families have
sought refuge many are still waiting for
aid
days after the floods and concerns are
growing over lack of basic necessities
there are elderly people here with us
and there are kids who need urgent care
they need food and medicines the
government needs to act
immediately others are also calling on
aid organizations for assistance
the floods approach within snakes and
scorpions and we need anti-venom drugs
we need international aid organizations
to step in and help before things get
worse as the rain season continues
al fao is one of the underdeveloped
rural areas in sudan
and nature worries it will take too long
before they get the help they need
hiba morgan al jazeera al-faw the
daughter of sudan